chers amis vous avez été très nombreuses
et très nombreux à rejoindre la cité
crac a participé à la rentrée politique
du modem soyez en remerciés malgré le
contexte sanitaire dégrader malgré une
rentrée difficile sur le plan économique
et social
nous avions besoin de ce moment pour
nous retrouver comme nous le faisons
chaque année
alors il aura manqué à cette rentrée le
soleil du morbihan les soirées animées
au bar du belambra les joggings au lever
du jour sur la plage pour les plus
courageux est tout simplement le plaisir
d'être ensemble
il aura aussi manqué notre cher mariale
à qui j'adresse un salut amical et
affectueux alors en attendant de nous
retrouver à guidel ou ailleurs je veux
en votre nom à tous tes touche adressé
un immense merci à l'équipe du siège qui
travaillent d'arrache-pied en lien avec
les équipes techniques pour monter et
faire vivre ces deux journées inédite
merci à gina héloïse olivia virginie
caroline seul m filomena delphine martin
vincent alexandre alan malo et carole
j'en oublie peut être certain il me le
pardonneront merci à eux
merci aussi à tous nos intervenants à
peu près une centaine membres du
gouvernement parlementaire mais
responsables nationaux responsables
départementaux qui ont répondu présent
merci aux jeunes démocrates et aux
commandos de bénévoles qui ont
littéralement mis le feu aux réseaux
sociaux
tout le week end merci aussi à l'équipe
d'université 133 pour sa participation à
nos travaux et puis merci à vous toutes
et tous d'avoir participé activement au
travers de vos questions à nos échanges
après ces deux journées de débats de
très grande qualité ce qui m'a frappé
c'est la force la force de notre
engagement
alors que notre pays notre europe et
d'une certaine manière notre humanité
sont à la croisée des chemins
j'ai ressenti le désir
profond désir d'action l'envi que dans
le monde qui s'ouvre devant nous nos
idées prennent toute leur place et
certaines des idées que nous défendons
depuis longtemps maintenant se sont
imposés la réactivation du commissariat
général au plan ta nomination
cher françois été salutaire évidemment
tant il était important que nous
puissions réarmer notre capacité
d'anticipation et reprendre notre destin
en main et inscrire la politique dans le
temps long mais c'est aussi la
reconnaissance d'une voie singulière qui
a été la tienne cher françois d'un cap
que nous allons tenu malgré les vents
contraires
alors merci et bravo à toi françois
autres idées que nous défendons depuis
longtemps celle d'une europe plus forte
plus solidaire plus indépendante
il ya quelques mois encore cette idée
paraissait presque désuète dans une
europe en trois ou doute en proie aux
désunion et en proie au processus du
brésil dont michèle bernier nous a si
bien décrit les enjeux tout à l'heure
mais le 21 juillet dernier à l'aube
l'europe s'est réveillé de sa torpeur et
sous l'impulsion du président de la
république de la chancelière allemande
une solidarité nouvelle est née entre
les peuples d'europe qui ont décidé de
se doter
face à la crise d'un plan de relance
commun d'une dette commune et de
ressources propres
c'est évidemment fondamental mais il
faudra aller plus loin je pense
notamment à la règle de l'unanimité qui
à bien des égards est un boulet et qui
limite notre capacité d'action et donc
notre indépendance
je pense aussi à ceux qui se joue au
drame qui se joue aujourd'hui en
méditerranée
il y a quelques semaines encore
en grèce nous pouvons rester insensibles
à la situation de ces demandeurs d'asile
qui frappent à la porte cette semaine la
commission européenne présentera son
pack pour les migrations et je compte
pour nos députés sur nos députés
européens pour contribuer à ce pacte
dans la fidélité à nos valeurs car c'est
la fidélité à nos valeurs c'est notre
unité notre cohésion que mark puis
patrick après lui ont su faire vivre à
l'assemblée au sein du groupe
parlementaire qui en ont fait son
attractivité et qui lui ont permis de
s'élargir temps l'unité est attractive
l'unité mais aussi une certaine manière
de faire de la politique dans le respect
de la diversité des opinions et dans la
convivialité et vous en avez pu vous
rendre compte hier lors du forum des
parlementaires
je veux remercier fabien lainé et
geneviève darrieussecq d'avoir accueilli
cette année les journées parlementaires
dans les landes qui ont été une
magnifique démonstration du sérieux et
de la cohésion du groupe modèle bref
c'est ce groupe renforcé clie de la
majorité parlementaire dirigée par notre
premier ministre jean castex qui nous
fait l'honneur de sa présence tout à
l'heure ce groupe qui défendra au
parlement sous la présidence de patrick
les priorités que nous avons abordés
ensemble tout au long du week end
je pense évidemment à la résorption des
fractures territoriales à la reconquête
des territoires de tous les territoires
de la république sur laquelle jacqueline
gourault veille attentivement je pense à
la revitalisation de nos institutions de
notre vie démocratique qui ne se fera
que par l'éveil
de la conscience civique chère sarah et
par l'instauration de la proportionnelle
car nous ne pouvons nous résoudre à
accepter la progression constante de
l'abstention à tous les scrutins
nous ne pouvons non plus nous résoudre
au discrédit qui est jeté sur le
parlement par des citoyens qui ne
comprennent pas pourquoi ils n'y sont
pas représentés
je pense évidemment à la promotion d'une
écologie des solutions d'une écologie
des résultats dans les démocrates pour
la planète ont débattu hier soir et dont
nos parlementaires et nos élus locaux se
sont déjà emparés pour faire des
propositions très concrètes et très
efficace
je pense aussi à la lutte contre toutes
les formes d'inégalités qui passe
évidemment et avant tout par l'éducation
chars nathalie mais aussi par une
meilleure partagent une meilleure
association des salariés à la richesse
qui est créé et c'est la raison pour
laquelle le groupe défendra la
participation l'intéressement et
l'actionnariat salarié dans le cadre de
la discussion du plan de relance
cet automne à l'assemblée puis je pense
évidemment à la question des solidarités
qui est si importante pour notre famille
politique la question des familles et la
question des solidarités
intergénérationnelles avec la poursuite
de la création de la cinquième branche
de la sécurité sociale relative à
l'autonomie qui a été initié cet été par
un amendement du groupe modem toutes ces
priorités nous les porterons aussi
devant les électeurs ensemble en mars
prochain
souhaitons qu'elle soit l'occasion
taliance victorieuse cher stanislas
guérini dans le respect de nos
différences et avec une ambition commune
avec alice lemoal avec richard ramos et
avec toute l'équipe du secrétariat
général du siège nous serons à vos côtés
aux côtés des candidats aux côtés des
mouvements départementaux pour les
accompagner dans cette fois
et j'ai bon espoir que lorsque nous nous
retrouverons l'année prochaine dans le
morbihan ou ailleurs nous aurons de très
nombreux conseillers départementaux et
régionaux à féliciter ainsi que quelques
présidents de région suivez mon regard
ces priorités nous les porterons aussi
au delà de 2021 avec en ligne de mire
2022 le chantier de réflexion que nous
avons initié l'année dernière à guidel
universités 133 auquel vous avez été un
millier à participer au travers des
auditions au travers de la consultation
publique ce chantier va se poursuivre
nous avons nous démocrates l'obligation
ardente de participer d'être au
rendez-vous de 2022 et le congrès de du
mois de décembre sera un moment
important une étape importante sur ce
chemin dans le temps incertain
un certain que nous sommes en train de
traverser il faut que collectivement
nous soyons vigilants il faut que nous
soyons en veille car la démocratie vous
le savez elle ne se décrète pas elle ne
tombe pas du ciel elle n'est jamais
acquise
c'est un sillon qui nous appartient de
labourer et de semaine avec de la
patience avec de la détermination et
avec du coeur avec l' envie de changer
le monde de faire évoluer le cours des
choses comme françois nous y habiter
hier après midi c'est exactement les
sens le rôle d'un mouvement politique
celui d'éveiller les consciences celui
de produire des idées nouvelles
celui de les défendre et celui de les
mettre en oeuvre
si vous êtes là aujourd'hui si nous
avons fait citer pendant ces deux jours
c'est que vous partagez cette même
conviction alors nous comptons sur vous
que vive la cité démocrate que vive la
république
et que vive la france